kim kardashian is focusing on work and
her children
in life what i've learned is you just
kind of have to go with it
after rumors have been swirling that
kanye west has moved on to someone new
a source tells e.t she isn't concerned
on her ex's dating life
i don't know where these rumors come
from she has quote
more important things to deal with and
is really focused on her family
in february the mom of four filed for
divorce from the rapper after six years
of marriage
the two share seven-year-old north
five-year-old saint
three-year-old chicago and two-year-old
song
the source says their kids spend the
majority of their time with mom and
she's making sure they get a lot of
family time
saying quote kim is really going out of
her way to make sure the kids are
preoccupied at all times
ensuring that they are busy and keeping
them living in the moment
kim has more control over their
schedules if kanye does see them
kim will have a say in what that entails
the source admits
things can get overwhelming for kim but
the support from her family
and loved ones has been a game changer i
feel like we are so blessed to have
the best support system and the best
family to
really just support each other no matter
what we're going through
but she's finding it difficult to move
on from their split
and their divorce is still pretty
emotional and not fully resolved the
source says
if you remember kim broke down in tears
over her marriage troubles with kanye
on keeping up with the kardashians
during part one of the series finale
i think he deserves someone that can go
support his every move
and go follow him all over the place and
move to wyoming i can't do that
he should have a wife that supports his
every move and travels with him and does
everything and i can't
i feel like a [ __ ] failure that it's
like a third marriage
yeah i feel like a loser but i can't
even think about that like i want to be
happy
although kim and kanye experienced
highly publicized issues prior to their
split
it's clear there's still plenty of love
between the exes
at the end of the day life is about
being happy being
who you are on tuesday kim celebrated
kanye's 44th birthday by posting
throwback pictures
on her instagram including a childhood
pic of kanye
one of just the two of them and another
of him and their kids
she even shared this family photo
writing love you for life